الركن المتقاعد واصف عريقات الخبير في
الشؤون الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه اللواء
واصف ايضا اهم ما رصه في الساعات الماضيه
عن طبيعه العمليات استمرار ايضا العمليات
حتى في المناطق الشماليه في التفاح
والزيتون
وغيرها يعني بعد مرور 106 ايام انا اعتقد
لا يوجد عمليات عسكريه هو يوجد قصف وسيطره
بالنيران سواء كان بالط رات او بالمدفعيه
البريه او بالدبابات يعني الدور دور
الجنود الاسرائيليين المفترض بعد مرور 106
ايام يكون دور رئيسي ويكون هناك يعني
تحييد لسلاح الجو وسلاح المدفعيه وللد
بابات ايضا بمعنى ان هي هذه المرحله هي
مرحله يعني تحقيق انجازات ميدانيه على
الارض وهي مرحله ترجل الجنود الاسرائيليين
ولكن الامور معكوسه تماما يعني ما يجري
الان هو سيطره حتى الان من خلال الطائرات
من خلال المدفعيه ومن خلال الدبابات
والجرافات الجنود الاسرائيليين يعملون في
المرحله الاستثنائيه جدا وهذا ما يؤكد
بعدم قدرتهم على تحقيق الانجازات والاهداف
حتى لو بقوا فتره طويله على الارض لانه
حينما نشاهد المقاتلين الفلسطينيين وغزاره
الاشتباكات مع الجنود ومع الاليات
الاسرائيليه هذا يؤكد بانه السيطره
الميدانيه ما زالت للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
وما زال المقاومه الفلسطينيه يملك القدرات
القتاليه والمهارات الميدانيه حينما نشاهد
اشرطه الفيديو
كيف يعني ينصب المقاتلين الفلسطينيين
الكمائن للدبابات للدبابات وليس للجنود
لانه الجنود دائما وابدا محاطين بالدبابات
وهذه ملاحظه يعني اع اعتقد انه العالم
الان يشاهدها هذا ان دل على شيء يدل على
تدني الروح المعنويه عند الجنود
الاسرائيليين وعن انخفاض الكفاءه القتاليه
بمعنى انه لا يستطيع التحرق في الميدان
دون ان يكون هناك جرافه امامه او دون ان
يكون هناك يعني دبابه تحميه لفهم طبيعه ما
يمكن تسميته بانجاز او غير ذلك اللواء
واصف هنا اعود الى تصريحات سابقه لقاده
عسكريين اسرائيليين بانه في حال عدم وجود
رؤيه للمراحل القادمه تحديدا سياسيا هذا
سيؤدي الى تاكل المنجز العسكري كما قال
هؤلاء القاده العسكريون هل ما نشاهده الان
خاصه في المناطق الشماليه حيث يقول الجيش
بانه انجز الجانب الاهم في هذه العمليه هل
هذا مثال على تاكل ما كان يصفه القاده
العسكريون بانه تاكل الانجازات
العسكريه اولا لم يكن هناك انجازات عسكريه
اذا ما لاحظنا اخي عبد القادر يعني
الانجازات الوحيده التي نفذها الجيش
الاسرائيلي حتى الان هي تد تمير البنيه
التحتيه حرب الاباده الجماعيه التطهير
العرقي استشهاد
24500 شهيد فلسطيني 61000 جريح 70% من
المباني التي تم تدميرها يعني هذا هذا هو
الانجاز العسكري حقيقه الاعتقالات
الاعتقالات للشباب للفتيات للرجال
والتحقيق معهم وتعذيبهم والاعدامات
الميدانيه لهم اي تدمير الجامعات ما معنى
تدمير جامعه بالامس جامعه الاسراء وكانوا
وكانوا قد وصلوا اليها منذ اسبوع او
اسبوعين تقريبا اذا نحن نتحدث عن جيش يعمل
بعقليه الثار والانتقام لا يوجد لديه
انجازات عسكريه حتى الان انا بتقديري هم
ينفذون يعني توصيه كامبل بنرمان عام 1905
حينما قال زرع جسم غريب في المنطقه يحول
دون وحدتها ويعمل على تفتيتها وتجهيل هم
الان يعني معركتهم معركه مع الوعي
الفلسطيني لانه هناك وعي جديد شكله
الفلسطيني في الجبهه الداخليه الاسرائيليه
تقول انه لا يمكن هزيمه هذا الفلسطيني
وهزيمه الجيش الاسرائيلي اصبحت واقعه شكرا
فبت شكرا عفوا شكرا لك واعتذر من كمين رام
الله اللواء الركن متقاعد واصف عريقات
الخبير في الشؤون الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه